[Music]
so again welcome everybody to the second
lecture this one is called play like a
pro well what can I say
that we've just had the candidates
tournament in Berlin it was a eight
player double round-robin tournament
featuring some of the world's very very
strongest players with the exception of
the world champion Magnus Carlsen the
entire idea of the event is to produce a
challenger to Magnus Carlsen so the
winner of this eight player double
round-robin
will win the tournament and the right to
challenge Magnus and it's the worst
tournament in the world to play because
essentially is only one prize the first
you want to be challenger to the world
champion and it's an exceptionally hard
tournament to win of the eight players I
think everybody went in its tournament
with a 15% chance which means a hundred
and twenty percent if Magnus Carlsen
entered this field there's no guarantee
whatsoever that he would win in fact I
think his chances of winning the
tournament are probably 20% to 25% at
the start meaning you have to play this
tournament four times or even five times
for Magnus to be the clear winner so
everybody's in there with a shout and I
had four favorites for this tournament
of course the two Americans Wesley so
and Fabiana come on guys you can do it
being elderly myself Vladimir Kramnik
how sweet the 14th world champion versus
the current world champion that would be
a great matchup the old lion and the
young lion and finally my fourth pick
out of the eight players was LaVon LaVon
was essentially the Player of the Year
in 2017 at one time he was the number
two player in the world by far there was
Magnus LaVon and then the rest of the
world and I thought of him as a clear
favorite going into the tournament maybe
I had him at 16% of chances of winning
he finished last Oh painful painful
painful event there was some incredible
drama to the event in the 12th round the
two leaders of the tournament Fabiano
and Jackie Schechter are married are off
Shack where the two leaders and they
both lost in round 12 it made the field
wide open and there was many as many as
five players in the last two rounds that
could have potentially won the
tournament and they were Fabiano still
Shak Sergey Kuryakin Dingle Erin and
Alexandre grew shocked everybody had a
thrilling final two games and Fabiano
pulled it out and he won his last two
games to win and become challenger so
we're all extremely proud of his success
but I was also looking at the games of
Levon Aronian and even when the games
were not decisive in this candidates
tournament they were wild affairs the
draws were incredibly exciting this is
such a game Levon Aronian versus
Alexander Grisham at the time that this
game was played we didn't know the fates
of the players we didn't know that Levon
was going to tumble tumble tumble down
to the final position and Grichuk didn't
know that he would potentially be vying
for first okay so here we go and
Alexander Grichuk is a very awkward
player to prepare for as white because
on the one hand he could play Greenfeld
the other hand he could play King's
Indian he can play many forms of the
benoni z-- and you just don't know what
kind of mood he's in for so with the
move f2 f3 LaVon is trying to be cagey
and avoid the potential for a groom fell
defense and he's trying to steer the
game oops
now what did I do I did something wrong
he's trying to steer the game into a
Kings Indian with f3 so he's hoping
sorry for that going up and down he's
hoping to avoid a Greenfeld and he wants
to play a King's Indian well the next
thing you know
excuse me the players are in a Benoni
it's kind of a benoni Kings into you
okay all of these moves are very very
well known theoretical you can go into a
database and you can find a thousand
games or more amongst grandmasters from
the starting position many many more
moves to be played but there are many
approaches that white can take in this
position and LaVon decided that he
wanted to put his Kings Knight this
night on over here oops
excuse me I'm so used to chess base
[Music]
yeah I think I could you mean just go to
be oh there we go okay yeah this was
much better thank you so much for that
okay so this is the position
oops not quite yet there so why just
puts his night on g3 and his intention
is to advance these pawns as he
completes his development age five okay
this is a very this is the latest and
greatest and benoni theory the idea with
this move is black wants to push away
this night from g3 and to gain some
space on the kingside Bishop e2 and now
we see another reason for this h5 move
Knight h7 so the idea is that black
first of all black opens up his bishop
on this diagonal excuse me he opens up
the bishop many times black wants to
attack white center with a move f7 f5
okay so this is still very well known
but this is a kind of a latest wrinkle
for white the move Bishop f4 attacks
this pawn on d6 and it basically commits
black to making a decision Grisha play
Queen e7 defending the pawn he could
also have considered the move Knight e5
white usually plays for Queen d2 in
these positions and I think that Grichuk
didn't want to block his bishop which is
why he played the move Queen e7 Queen d2
h4 again pushing the night away and the
night comes back well
we can see that white has this very nice
control of the center but black has a
lot of dynamic possibilities including
the move g5 he's pushing White's pieces
backwards as night on the f1 the bishop
on the e2 are a little cramped and
passive 95 okay so Grichuk has in mind
that maybe on a good day he's going to
push his H pawn the pawn on f3 could be
potentially weak but more importantly
black if for example move like castles
black is interested in potentially
attacking white center with f5 okay
after 95 g3 LaVon fights back to try to
gain back some of the territory that
he's been losing on the kingside if
black is so obliging and makes a mistake
of castling look what he's done he's
allowed white to open the G file the
blacks king is already in some troubles
so after g3 Bishop d7 developing and
notice it that oh sorry
just a second yeah just a second yeah
okay just wanted to make sure of
something exactly at this moment black
Griffith had a very important choice I
want to put it like that he could have
considered the move
g4 pressing his initiative on the
kingside in case of f4 to check
takes ticks and this would have created
a whole new level of chaos Black's idea
is that it's not so easy for white to
simply win this pawn on f3 maybe even on
a good day this Bishop will come to h3
and maybe end up on g2 protecting the
part that's a very unusual situation
Grisha decided to play the shifty 7
takes takes rook g1 f5 and you notice
that both players Kings are still in the
middle it was like white didn't want a
castle short when black is kind of
keeping his options open I think that
this is a very good lesson for a lot of
club players to appreciate that
professional players really want to keep
as many of their options open as
possible they're not really trying to
commit themselves right out of the bag
okay so after f7 f5f for attacking the
knight notice also that there's this
explosive move Bishop h5 check in the
position which would force blacks King
to move Knight g4
now in a certain sense black is very
happy
the position is chaotic
which is what benoni players are trying
to do is create a lot of complications
where it's very easy for both players to
find all the mistakes in the position
also what black is trying to do is break
down white center if you look at white
center the pawns on d5 e4 f4 really
control a lot of space so black is
trying to win the pawns and one of the
things he wants to do is he wants to
take this bishop and this bishop has a
beautiful beautiful view over the long
diagonal d5 deeply calculated move pawn
takes e5 d6 okay so why does sacrifice a
pawn to open up the position maybe on a
good day he's planning to play Knight to
b5 to night c7 check maybe he wants to
go Knight d5 to c7 in check and also he
could potentially pick up this pawn on
c5 with Bishop Bishop e3 tech c5 white
is also making a home for his own king
queenie 695 threatening to go Knights e7
check for King the king queen and rook
what we call a family fork all together
now okay rook c8 black shows his
intention of sacrificing in exchange for
the night pawn maybe this should have
been in my first lecture the secret life
of a fun
because look at that pond it's it's just
you know one square from promotion
context okay again the position is
really messed up
it's complete chaos on the board if you
take this Bishop is under attack if you
move the bishop to take upon well be
careful your your your queen your your
Bishop and King our pin and the
promotion square is protected and black
is going to win another minor piece what
do you think LaVon played this was deep
with the bishop bishop takes this one
okay
if the bishop takes on f4 and that's a
very logical move just a second
I like this turn very much I think the
problem was the bishop comes to the
center attacks the rook if the rook
moves here I believe the problem was the
bishop ends up trapping this rook so
that was one line that LaVon did not
like other guesses
sorry but Bishop Bishop where this month
ah well then that would just be Bishop
takes right so so it was like it felt
like it was a choice between Bishop
takes e5 and Bishop takes f4 Luhan found
another choice
rook d1 what the heck was that
rook d1 well what's going on here you
tell me what would have happened if
black had captured the bishop what was
what was White's intentions to some kind
of remote night - no no no no LaVon had
this idea in mind
ooh Bishop b5 and now he gets a queen oh
and this was like this was going to be
very very difficult for blacks King
blacks King is going to be in real real
danger let's go back so this is White's
idea is to take on d7 to play Bishop b5
and there's another idea in case of
taking up squeeze me and KITT yes that's
right there's another idea Knight takes
the idea here again is I want to take on
d7 and if you take here just a second
there was this there was this crazy idea
takes here takes here takes here it's
like what the heck is going on takes
here it should be five and again another
Queen is coming on the board
whoa so I was having an incredible
amount of fun working out all of those
ideas where the bishop gets captured and
then this Queen takes d7 and Bishop b5
Sasha played a move I hadn't expected at
all 95 whoa what's the idea behind that
the idea behind that move is if you move
your Bishop let's say Bishop takes
oops NIDA three check and mate
whoa where did that come from
okay so now LaVon produced Queen check
Bishop takes check King here check King
here I mean pieces are hanging Kings are
flying King in the middle of the board
rook d6 okay rook d6 where's the Queen
gonna go Bishop is hanging you can't go
Queen e8 to protect the bishop because
then he's got rooked down and you lose
the Queen so Sasha played Queen f7 and
now there was an incredible move that
LaVon didn't play how many of you want
to take a bishop with check me too me
too
like white he played Queen check here he
didn't take the bishop with check and
everybody wondered why doesn't he do
this check well obviously that's a
bishop but check the King has to move
now White's Queen is hanging the bishop
on e3 is hanging and
he has missed a very key point the key
point if LaVon had taken the bishop with
check he would win the game
ooh he would win the game just simply
like that how check King here queen
takes e5 queen takes e5 well LaVon had
missed was that after takes here what is
White's move what is White's move yes
yes rook takes g4 and Queen takes Queen
f2 check I just move and it's blacks
King that is in real trouble not White's
King so there was another moment here -
just a second here takes the bishop with
a check King h7 takes the pawn there was
another move
what about Knight e4
mmm what are we gonna do about 94 oh my
word
the problem is if we move our queen
he'll take the rook which protects the
you will take the rook with the knight
which protects the Queen and if we take
well he can take and the game is not
worse for black so we need a move here
for white that's extra special you need
a really really good move for white
extra extra special
yes yes we could sacrifice the Queen
it's a brilliant idea
rook takes now we can't take the rook
because after Bishop d3 this knight is
pinned it can't move because of the and
the next turn white is going to take the
night with check so we take the Queen
and now check you can't put the bishop
in the way because the two rooks either
rook could capture the bishop your King
has to go back and now let's yes rook da
check wait then you what should white
play Mara's
Bishop D for the rook is hanging bishops
well he can take that guy - exactly
rook takes first King takes then Bishop
takes now normally three pieces is good
enough three minor pieces are good
enough - for the Queen
but here you got three minor pieces in a
ruck and tuitions so why would have been
completely winning in this variation
LaVon
had seen this position tonight efore
that he missed this extra special move
rook takes chief for which would have
won in the game so it's something crazy
like that right so instead the game goes
Queen da check which confused everybody
because those people had also missed the
94 resource Gris ship like Queen back
Bishop takes Knight back now it's crazy
because blacks an exchange down but he's
got his King in relative safety
he's got a pond and this Bishop on g7 is
a really good piece Bishop c4 there was
a change King came up change and here
now at the time that they had reached
this position a lot of folks still felt
that LaVon was winning but I wasn't one
of them I felt that the position was
really really complicated blacks Knights
are crawling around they have good
support squares the pawn on b2 is
hanging and after this move Knight g5
black is threat
Knight f3 check with a fork on the king
of the rook rook g2 getting out of the
fork and also protecting the pawn on b2
those nights are really hopping around
the board
Bishop b8 going after the pub getting
the bishop out black's pieces that are
taking up fantastic squares in the
middle of the board age 395 Bishop d5 so
both players are doing their absolute
best to keep their pieces as active as
possible it's funny this bishop on b8 is
actually looking at the a 7-pound but
it's also patrolling the center knight
d3 check now the players had been in
time trouble understandably King e2 and
here I actually think that grish ik
faltered and he should have played he
played in the game night c1 check and
that in my view was a mistake he should
have simply captured this pawn on me to
give me your pawns baby and after for
example Bishop takes a 7 it was time oh
sorry
there is Knight c3 check that he had to
he first has to take oops excuse me you
first have to take a variation
take-take-take
i had analyzed a variation like this
which is working out in blacks favor but
just to make the time control Knight c1
check the King came back Knight to d3 so
in a sense no harm no foul because
there's also there's not only this bond
hanging but this pawn on h3
can also be checked and captured okay
Knight to d2 knight back to f6 Bishop f3
and Wow after all of this excitement
here the players agreed to a draw and I
was like oh man you know they had to a
too much excitement for one day
but I thought even here there was a
there was a lot of potential the very
annoying thing about this position was I
thought that the game was going to
continue night b2 and like this I I was
so impressed by this game and everything
that was going on in this game I turned
on the chess engine and went over the
game very carefully the final position
the chess engine says zero zero zero
that the game was even I like oh man if
yeah it's rich but it's even now I just
like to bring our attention back to what
I thought was that a spectacular moment
right here
when LaVon played the move rook t1 I was
like wow what kind of crazy move is rook
d1 and the computer thought it was a
mistake rook t1 was a mistake the
computer thought LaVon should Castle
what it still plays rook d1 but gets the
King out of the pins on the e-file and I
thought okay well I gotta ask the stupid
computer what it intended to do against
this ugh the idea was remember when the
rook went to d1 there was a trick that
went Queen takes Queen takes Bishop here
Hey correct
now there's Bishop takes B to check and
apparently this makes all the difference
in the world that this Bishop takes B to
check the King goes here there was
something like tags queen king up and
black is attacking White's King as well
but the computer says castles was the
right move and then after takes Knight
takes III knight takes III now we've got
that same variation as before ii ii how
did that go ah no i was a bishop h5
check mmm i'm not sure maybe it was here
Bishop b5 and i think the idea first of
all I'm threatening the Queen because
now the bishop is pin to riot and if you
take my bishop I think or I could also
check to h5 that might be the winning
line as well something like this if you
go King here check
and make next turn ooh so here was this
incredible tactical wild wild game that
was like a rollercoaster ride for the
players for the spectators and the game
ends in a draw and this was got the kind
of professional game that the candidates
tournament was all about there was so
many really high-quality decisive games
but sometimes you forgot that the draw
the games that were draws were not
boring there were a lot of a lot of fun
and after watching this game I guess you
guys know how to play like a pro right
[Music]
you
[Music]